cette vidéo est sponsorisé par kambly un
service de tuteurs anglophone en ligne
je vous en reparle à la fin de la vidéo
you les potes j'espère que vous allez
bien et que la vie n'est pas trop
difficile
elle l'est elle est on va pas se mentir
c'est c'est très dur c'est très dur et
donc du coup il ya quelques mois j'ai
tenté nouvelle routine une routine
emprunté à l'un des grands de ce monde
marcorelle quand machiavel parler des
empereurs romains il avait une
expression c'était les cinq bons
empereur et parler des cinq premiers
empereurs de la dynastie des antonins
c'était nerva trajan adrien antonin le
pieux et marco l on les appelait les
cinq bons empereur parce que pendant
cette période l'as rome et l'empiré
romain était extrêmement prospère
anecdotes sur cette période les
empereurs ont choisi leurs successeurs
parce qu'en fait ils n'avaient pas
d'héritier sauf par corel le dernier qui
a eu un fils qui était une énorme merde
tellement nul qu'on lui a donné le nom
d'un meuble voilà il s'applique qu'aux
modes
il était même pire que cette vanne pour
vous dire à quel point ça allait pas
agde dans l'anecdote marcorelle a eu
beaucoup d'enfants à peu près 13 et on a
très peu en fait qu'ils sont arrivés
jusqu'à l'âge adulte à peu près 5 et
jeudi beaucoup d'à peu près parce que je
veux pas rentrer dans les sources et
c'est parce que c'est pas du tout le
sujet de cette vidéo est d'ailleurs je
vais fermer la parenthèse tout de suite
il faut savoir que l' empire romain ne
sera jamais aussi riche que sous le
règne de marc aurèle marque ol qui était
aussi réputé pour sa sagesse un point on
l'appelait carrément l'empereur
philosophe il a d'ailleurs écrit pensée
pour moi même et de ce livre j'essayais
de tirer une routine de l'empereur le
plus sage de tous les temps donc la
première étape c'est de lire le livre
est donc parfois dans certaines
citations certains passages etc
on peut isoler et créer une routine me
suis aussi basé sur des choses que je
savais déjà parce que marc aurèle est
affiliée au stoïcisme et le stoïcisme
est une philosophie qui me passionne
vraiment depuis toujours
notez bien que j'ai dit affiliés au
stoïcisme parce qu' à aucun moment marc
aurèle ne se définit comme stoïcien
d'ailleurs il rejette pas par exemple la
philosophie d'epicure puisqu'il ya un
moment où il cite epicure dans son livre
je vais donc vous lire à présent des
passages qui ont permis d'établir une
routine comme ça vous voyez vraiment le
processus du truc et je trouve que c'est
vraiment un livre intéressant et qu'il
ya des passages intéressants et donc le
ca fait plaisir de vous les lire
voilà très peu d'affaires dit on si tu
veux te conserver en bonne humeur
de cette manière tu récolteras non
seulement la bonne humeur qui provient
du devoir accompli mais encore celle qui
provient d'une activité modérée
en effet la plupart de nos paroles et de
nos actions n'étant pas indispensable si
on les retranche on en a que plus de
loisirs et de tranquillité c'est
pourquoi il faut en toute occasion se
remettre en mémoire
ceci ne serait-il pas une des choses qui
ne sont pas indispensables et non
seulement il faut retrancher les actions
qui ne seraient pas indispensables
il faut aussi élaguer des idées là il
s'agit de ce qu'on appelle communément
une tout doux voilà faire une tout doux
et ne pas trop la charge c'est un gros
problème quand on fait des to do le fait
de les surcharger parce qu'on surestime
en fait notre capacité à pouvoir faire
des choses dans la journée est vraiment
il faut pas parce que très vite on se
rend compte qu'on n'arrive pas à finir
et donc on rentre dans une boucle de
dévaluation de soi même et c'est à 11 0
h une j'arrive pas être productif et ses
mauvais plan je pense que j'aurai
l'occasion d'en reparler sur cette
chaîne quand on parlera de productivité
et ses expressions aboli l'imagination
arrête cette agitation de pantin
délimite le moment présent reconnaît ce
qui arrive à toi ou à autrui divisé
analyse l'objet données en sa cause et
en sa matière pense à ta dernière heure
la faute commise par cet homme laisse là
où elle a pris naissance
et si évidemment on reconnaît les
principes forts de la méditation à
savoir calmer son esprit se recentrer
sur le moment présent et ne pas se
laisser troubler par les événements
extérieurs niveau routine matinale
maintenant voilà ce qui nous sort dès
l'aurore dis-toi davance je rencontrerai
un indiscret un ingrat info ben un
envieux un égoïste tous ces vices ont
été causés en eux par l'ignorance des
biens et des mots nous voilà on est dans
une préparation mentale
chaque matin de s'imaginer voilà les
gens qu'on pourrait rencontrer les
moments désagréables qu'on pourrait
vivre et surtout se rappeler que c'est
jamais intentionnel et que c'est dû à
une ignorance effectivement l'idée c'est
que plus on est préparé et plus on saura
mieux réagir ça paraît assez évident il
donne aussi un conseil pour sortir du
lit et schultz qui a c'est rassurant
quoi c'est fou que à l'époque déjà il
avait
parfois ce problème là de réussir à
sortir du lit je vous lis ça tout de
suite c'est un extrait un peu long mais
je trouve qu'il est marrant et
intéressant donc je vais vous lire en
entier je pense le matin quand ils te
coûte de réveiller que cette pensée soit
présente c'est pour faire oeuvre
d'hommes que je me réveille
vais-je donc être encore de méchante
humeur parce que je pars accomplir ce à
cause de quoi je suis fait en vue de
quoi j'ai été mis dans ce monde
suis-je constitué à cet effet de rester
couché et me tenir au chaud sous des
couvertures et donc la licra un dialogue
lui-même c'est plus agréable et tu donc
fait pour l'agrément est en général et
tu fais pour la passivité ou pour
l'activité ne vois tu pas que les
plantes les paresseux les fourmis les
araignées les abeilles font leurs tâches
propres et contribue pour leur part au
bon agencement du monde
alors toi tu ne veux pas faire ce qui
convient à l'homme tu ne cours pas la
tâche qui est conforme à la nature
il faut bien se reposer oui d'accord
mais la nature a donné des bornes au
repos mais elle en a donné pour le
manger et le boire
et toi cependant ne dépasse tue pas les
bornes ce qui est suffisant faut-il agir
tu n'en ai plus tu restes au 2a du
possible c'est que tu ne te chéri pas
toi même sinon tu chériras nature et son
dessin d'autres qui aiment leur métier
se consume aux travaux qui s'y
rapportent
sans se baigner et sans manger toi
estimes tu - la nature que le ciseleur
son art le danseur la danse l'avare son
argent le vaniteux la gloriole ces gens
là quand leur passion les tiens ne
veulent ni manger ni dormir mais bien
plutôt à croître à mesure l'objet de
leurs efforts pour toi les actions
utiles à la communauté de par estelle
être inférieure et valoir moins de soins
je perds la vente est sûre le fait de
réussir à sortir du lit c'est pas un
truc que donc je vais parler dans cette
vidéo mais je trouvais ça hyper
intéressant son point de vue et est
encore une fois le fait qu'il en parlait
déjà à l'époque il réfléchit aussi pas
mal à la mort le fameux memento mori
souviens-toi que tu vas mourir puisqu'il
dit la chose suivante si l'un des dieux
te disais que tu seras mort demain ou en
tout cas après demain tu n'as tâcherai
plus guère d'importance à ce que ce fut
dans deux jours plus tôt que demain à
moins d'être le dernier des lâches car
quelle est la différence
de même ne croit pas que mourir après de
longues années plutôt que demain ce soit
un grand avantage et j'avoue que dit
comme ça effectivement il a pas si tort
autre élément intéressant sur la gloire
dans la mort et souviens toi encore que
chacun ne vit que le présent c'est
infiniment petit le reste ou bien il est
déjà vécu ou bien il est incertain
minimes et donc l'instant que chacun vit
minimes le coin où il le vit minimes
aussi la plus longue gloire posthume
donc voilà ça c'est les éléments que
j'ai tirée de bouquins pour faire une
routine à cela on peut rajouter un truc
que j'avais vu en cours de philo je
crois c'est le fait qu' il aimait bien
parfois dormir par terre
l'idée c'était de s'imposer une sorte
d'inconfort pour cultiver sa gratitude
par rapport au confort qu'ils avaient en
temps normal est aussi cultiver une
forme d'humilité
voilà bon après il a arrêté parce que sa
mère était contre d'après histoire
d'auguste qu'il ya un recueil de
biographies d'emprunt comme quoi même
quand on est empereur on a tous les
mêmes baronne donc du coup voilà ce que
ça donne en terme de routine memento
mori donc faire une déclaration de morts
chaque matin se préparer à une journée
de merde donc écrire ce qui pourrait mal
se passer dans la journée
méditez faire ça tout doux dormir sur le
sol une fois par semaine et cultiver sa
bienveillance et pour ça j'ai mis genre
acte d'altruisme a effectué dans la
semaine et grateful shower alors la
great food show hour c'est un truc qui
vient de certaines routines américaine
et/ou qui est sous la douche
pensez à trois choses pour lesquelles on
est reconnaissant alors il ya pas mal de
choses que je faisais déjà dans cette
routine comme par exemple ma déclaration
de mort c'est un truc que je fais tous
les matins depuis que j'ai 12 ans à peu
près c'est faux c'est faux je suis
parfois dépressifs mais pas à ce point
quand même donc voilà j'ai fait ça
pendant 30 jours
donc évidemment j'ai noté tout ça et
cetera je vais vous lire quelques
extraits pour que vous voyez l'ambulance
un petit peu memento mori pour mon
dernier jour sur terre je vais voir mon
home où est maman mousse est maintenant
bien je suis heureux comme une
impression de partir en accomplissant
mon devoir
memento mori je vais mourir ce soir ça
c'est frustrant de mourir quand on est
dans une phase décevante en terme de
productivité
j'aurais préféré partir quand prince
j'essaie d'être plus efficace
aujourd'hui pour à moins de regrets un
autre regret c'est de ne pas lire plus
voilà donc ça se promène de maury et
maintenant les projections de ce qui
pourrait mal se passer
accident de voiture je devais prendre la
voiture j'imagine ce jour-là transmettre
le qu'ovide que l'état de sa grave crise
inquiète et malade ne pas réussir à
avancer aujourd'hui
en fait je me rends compte en regardant
les jours que souvent ces trucs qui sont
très perso et
les choses dont on a peur que ça nous
arrive ça concerne des gens ça concerne
des situations très précise et c'est en
tout cas pour moi donc je peux
difficilement vous en parler mais les
voyait truc un peu marrant j'ai par
exemple l'âge et être nulle au podcast
donc je devais de enregistré un podcast
j'imagine et j'avais peur d'être d'être
nul voila c'est presque touchant alors
après autant de temps qu'est-ce que j'en
ai tiré ce que j'en ai tiré c'est bon
déjà c'est difficile de faire un vrai
avant après parce qu'il ya pas mal de
choses que je faisais déjà mais par
contre je me suis sentie clairement plus
sage plus beau et je pense que ça c'est
dû à quelques éléments clés déjà le fait
de penser autant à la mort je n'étais
pas habitué et c'était hyper intéressant
et c'est vrai que quelque part
l'exercice de penser à la mort et
l'exercice de ressentir de la gratitude
pour ce qu'on a très vite en fait se
rejoignaient parce que quand on pense à
la mort on pense à ce qu'on pourrait
laisser derrière soi et donc en fait on
se rend compte aussi de tout ce qu'on a
et de la chance qu'on peut avoir le
permis en poche et penser à ce que
j'allais laisser derrière moi est ce qui
du coup a les manques et forcément c'est
des choses pour lesquelles je ressens de
la gratitude donc c'est devenu redondant
mais ceci dit je trouve que penser à la
mort vraiment aussi souvent c'était il y
avait quelque chose de super sain là
dedans ça m'a permis aussi de voilà de
me recentrer sur l'essentiel et parfois
aussi de sortir un peu la tête du guidon
et ça rendait aussi tous les problèmes
moins importante parce que soit j'avais
un souci et il était pas grave et donc
bon je relativise est soit je vais un
souci et il était grave et façon il
allait se régler tout seul puisque
j'allais mourir
donc au final rien n'était vraiment
important quoi je pense que c'est
l'élément que j'ai ajoute à cette
routine et qui était plus intéressant
pour moi et ça a rejoint un vieil adage
stoïciens qui dit que vivre c'est
apprendre à mourir et ben memento mori
on est en plein dedans maintenant si je
ne méritais pas déjà je pense que c'est
la méditation qui aurait été le point le
plus important pour moi
trente jours c'est peut-être un peu
court pour voir vraiment tous les effets
etc
moi je médite déjà donc tous les jours
depuis
deux ans à nantes comme ça effectivement
ça être vachement à apprécier peut-être
le moment présent et c est ce truc
d'appréciation du moment présent
c'est vraiment clé dans n'importe quelle
philosophie du bonheur après j'imagine
pas forcément marcorelle se mettre en
tailleur comme ça et méditer de cette
manière là la mutation c peut se faire
de plein de façons différentes on peut
méditer en marchant peut méditer en
mangeant on peut méditer en vous êtes en
faisant n'importe quoi
donc j'imagine plus marc aurèle dans ces
situations là vous avez fait quelques
tips je crois dans une vidéo pour la
méditation je la mets en description
mais en gros ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que ça permet de vachement
cultiver ce truc d'observation et donc
de ne plus être dans le jugement et donc
on réagit moins aux stimuli extérieurs
et donc ça c'est essentiel dans une
philosophie stoïcienne faire c'est tout
doux point extrêmement important aussi
je pas le développer là parce que comme
je voulais dit je vais faire mon avis
des vidéos ça tenait sur la productivité
on en parlait et cetera donc voilà j'ai
pas le développer ici mais tu sais des
choses que je faisais déjà de façon le
fait de se préparer à une journée de
merde c'est intéressant parce que ça
permet de projeter dans la journée mais
c'est quelque chose que là tout doux
fait déjà après ça peut être intéressant
aussi parce que tu es reconnaissant
envers ce qui se passe bien mais ça le
memento mori le fais déjà aussi donc à
première vue ça sert à rien mais j'ai
quand même trouvé que c'est intéressant
sur plusieurs jours en fait quand on
écrit etc
des fois on se rend compte que dans les
choses qu'on projette et qui pourraient
aller mal il ya des éléments qui
reviennent souvent on se rend pas
forcément compte quand on est dedans
mais en fait quand on regarde une vue
d'ensemble c'est intéressant parce que
des fois on se dit c'est marrant j'ai
toujours peur qu'il y ait un problème
avec telle personne ou bien j'ai
toujours peur qu'il ya un problème avec
tel projet est donc on voit ce qui est
source de stress
est ce qui est source de d'angoissant
fait finalement alors que quand on est
dedans on se rend pas forcément compte
puisque ben chaque journée s'enchaînent
et tous et c'est une nouvelle journée à
chaque fois donc pour ça j'ai trouvé ça
très intéressant
c'est pour ça aussi que je pense que
tout ce qui est memento mori ou ce truc
de projection dans ce qui pourrait aller
mal c'est important que ce soit écrit
comme une tout doux il faut que ce soit
écrit ces choses à dormir sur le sol une
fois par semaine c'est nul c'est nul
c'est de la grosse merde ça sert
absolument à rien ne fait pas ça ça se
mange pas grand chose à ajouter quoi
j'ai pas besoin de dormir par terre pour
me rendre compte que j'ai de la chance
d'avoir un lit en fait il suffit de me
projeter un moment a imaginé dans ma par
terre et je me dis c'est cool
d'avoir indiqué m et d'ailleurs je
voulais une citation de sénèque sur le
sujet que j'aime beaucoup
donc c'est un truc qui les créent à
lucilius je te conseille de ne pas
imiter ceux qui désirent
non pas s'améliorer mais se faire
remarquer et de ne pas introduire dans
sa tenue et ton genre de vie quoi que ce
soit qui attire l'attention
voilà je suis entièrement d'accord et
dernier élément de la routine cultiver
sa bienveillance bon je sais déjà de
manière générale à être bienveillants à
faire des actions altruistes et cetera
mais du coup ça m'a forcé à le faire à
des moments où j'étais peut-être plus
concentré sur moi et j'en avais
peut-être moins envie par exemple j'ai
accepté de faire des entretiens pour des
mémoires de fin d'études etc
c'est des demandes que je reçois
vraiment chaque semaine d'habitude
ch'tis toujours non parce que j'ai pas
envie de prendre du temps pour ça désolé
voilà j'espère que vous comprenez je
préfère prendre du temps pour faire mes
vidéos et vous transmettre ce genre de
choses
il a du coup je les fais et c'est vrai
que voilà sur le sur le coup on se sent
bien on a l'impression d'avoir fait un
truc utile
on sent de la fierté aussi on a
l'impression d'être une meilleure
personne tout simplement voilà et ça
c'est positif
du coup est ce que c'est une routine que
je recommande n'a pas vraiment pas
vraiment pourquoi je pense que il ya
moyen d'optimiser tout ça en fait je
trouve qu'elle est complexe à mettre en
place qu'on peut l'optimiser pour tirer
beaucoup de ses bénéfices sans avoir
tous ces inconvénients
par exemple la méditation et le mémento
maury ça je recommande à fond en fait je
pense que tout se joue au niveau de la
méditation et du memento mori parce que
de ces deux choses là en fait vont
découler plein d'autres choses comme par
exemple le fait de cultiver sa
bienveillance cultiver la gratitude etc
de manière générale il faut aussi sur
réconcilier avec la pensée de la mort
faut se confronter à ça je pense que
c'est un truc qu'on fait peut-être pas
assez dans notre société
tout simplement ça peut-être un peu trop
tabou etc je pense que vraiment il faut
briser tout ça ça sera une échelle
personnelle
il faut être hyper à l'aise en fait avec
avec le fait qu'on va mourir pourquoi
tout simplement
et évidemment c'est pas parce qu'on est
à l'aise avec le fait que de mourir qu
on a envie de mourir ou quoi que ce soit
précisé parce que j'ai des potes qui
savent que je suis un peu hypocondriaque
parfois il pourrait se dire bah mec
totalement pas envie de mourir oui j'ai
pas envie de mourir c'est vrai donc si
je peux éviter la mort je le ferai
maintenant si la mort vient bon et bien
qu'elle vienne quoi quelques pas mais
j'avoue je vais faire ce que je peux
quand même pour éviter qu'elle arrive je
trouve pas ça contradictoires et donc je
pense que s'il ya une méditation
et un manteau maury qui sont réguliers
et cetera il n'y a pas forcément ce
besoin de se forcer à faire des actions
altruistes
ça n'a pas de sens je trouve ça beaucoup
plus adéquat que cette action altruiste
elles viennent à un moment spontanée et
viennent naturellement et que et
viennent quand on a vraiment envie de le
faire quoi et je pense que ça c'est un
état d'esprit qui va découler de la
méditation et du memento mori qui seront
réguliers donc voilà si je devais garder
deux éléments de cette routine c'est ça
c'est cette mutation dmto maury essaie
aussi de temps en temps je trouve ça
intéressant de temps en temps à faire
cette projection négative dans la tout
doux c'est que quand vous faites votre
tout doux quotidienne j'espère que vous
le faites j'en avais parlé dans comment
bien travailler de chez soi est a priori
on est toujours en train travail chez
soi ou presque quand vous faites votre
toutou pourquoi pas à côté dire voilà ce
qui pourrait mal se passer et caetera et
en fait je pense que c'est intéressant
de le faire de temps en temps sur
plusieurs jours et ensuite de regarder
ça de se dire est ce qu'un truc qui
revient est ce que j'ai un problème avec
quelqu'un ou avec un projet que ceara et
comment je peux régler ce problème là et
est ce que c'est un truc que je veux
garder ou est ce que c'est un truc dont
je donne des bases au delà de ça c'est
un plaisir mais un plaisir de vous faire
une vidéo sur marc aurèle parce que
c'est un personnage que j'affectionne
tout particulièrement
et en plus le stoïcisme reste une de mes
philosophie préféré en tout cas celle à
laquelle je me suis le plus attaché je
pense dans ma vie ça et pas mal de
choses emprunté au bouddhisme mais
vraiment il ya une vraie convergence
donc c'est très similaire sur plein
d'aspects les amis je vais vous parler
de combis
kambly - déjà ils ont sponsorisé une
vidéo sur marc aurèle donc marquer
d'exception c'est un site qui vous
permet de rentrer en contact avec des
tuteurs qui sont anglophones
ok ils parlent ils sont natifs anglais
c'est dire que même mois ci par exemple
imaginons j'ai été excellent en anglais
je ne peux pas aller sur le site kambly
je peux pas être tuteur sur convives il
faut être vraiment natifs anglophones
c'est la nouvelle année c'est le moment
de mettre en place de nouvelles routines
et dans les nouvelles routines qui
reviennent très souvent il ya apprendre
une langue
et honnêtement la langue en priorité
qu'il faut apprendre dans notre monde
c'est l'anglais voilà pas se mentir
c'est l'anglais je m'en sert énormément
pour mes recherches sur les vidéos et
cetera pour suivre l'actualité pour
plein de choses
l'anglais c'est vraiment essentiel et
c'est difficile de
passé le problème quand on apprend une
langue c'est bon déjà apprendre une
langue c'est compliqué et tout un petit
peu laissé à l'abandon quoi on sait pas
trop comment l'entretenir et comment
tout c'est sa conversation discuter avec
des gens qui parlent cette langue là et
c est encore plus à une période comme la
nôtre où c'est impossible de voyager
quoi donc
c'est là où kambly je trouve est hyper
intéressant c'est que ça vous permet de
rentrer en relation avec des gens
discuter avec eux et c'est des gens qui
vont vous reprendre lorsque vous faites
des erreurs et c'est alors c'est vous
qui choisissez s'ils préfèrent kivu
reprennent tout de suite ou bien à la
fin de la conversation
en tout cas c'est c'est vraiment hyper
intéressant il faut constater que j'aime
beaucoup c'est que vous pouvez faire ça
par thématiques par exemple vous avez
envie de parler de films et de séries et
ben il ya des gens pour ça vous avez
envie de parler d'écologie et des gens
pour ça vous avez envie de parler
d'éducation et de élever les enfants etc
il ya des gens pour ça braie qui est
plein de recettes de sujet et ça c'est
hyper bien fais trop on peut aussi
choisir un professeur en fonction de son
accent par exemple donc ça c'est une
autre fonctionnalité qui peut être cool
et un autre qui fait que quand ben issa
peut être pas mal je trouve
c'est lorsque vous avez un oral à
préparer pour un examen ou une
présentation à faire en entreprise et c
est bien vous pouvez vous entraîner à le
faire avec quelqu'un de compliqué ça ça
peut être décisif si vous voulez essayer
conflit gratuitement ou pouvait le faire
il ya un code pour ça c'est le code
cyrus north
évidemment ça va aussi une réduction de
40% valable si vous prenez un abonnement
de 12 mois donc dans cette logique de
routine et de résolutions de l'année etc
ça peut être pas mal encore une fois le
code cyrus north et même d'ailleurs vous
avez des réductions en fait pour
n'importe quelle période de temps
toujours avec le code sur le nord c'est
ce que je vous ai dit que le code
c'était cyrus north
j'ai un doute c'est cyrus torse le code
si vous essayez certains éléments de
cette routine je veux bien votre avis en
commentaire j'espère que ces vidéos vous
aura plu voilà c'était vraiment un kif
pour moi de vous parler de marc aurèle
de stoïcisme etc
merci à combiner avoir sponsorisé une
vidéo sur marc aurèle ça fait plaise
merci pour tous vos retours sur la vidéo
du vaccin c'était champ mais on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine suivez moi
sur instagram
je balance des trucs tout le temps tu as
des story des matchs etc
si vous êtes une merde ne venait pas sur
instagram ne suivaient pas sur instagram
c'était resté sur youtube si vous voulez
j'ai besoin de gens cool j'ai besoin de
positivité et c'est ok merci
évidemment vous n'êtes pas une merde je
le sais vous seriez pas en train de
regarder une vidéo sur une routine de
marc aurèle bien sûr love peace ciao